Prof: This morning we're
going to begin making the
transition from the classical
utilitarian doctrine of Jeremy
Bentham's to the neoclassical
doctrine that was championed by
a number of different figures in
the late nineteenth and early
twentieth century,
and we're going to end up by
focusing on John Stuart Mill as
the principle expositor of
neoclassical utilitarianism.
And where we're headed is for a
doctrine that I'm going to call
the rights-utility synthesis.
The rights-utility synthesis
signals that we're looking for
an attempt to put together both
a commitment to utilitarian
efficiency that's grounded in
science on the one hand,
and respect for individual
rights that's grounded in the
workmanship ideal on the other
hand.
And we're not going to actually
get to the rights-utility
synthesis as it's expressed in
politics by John Stuart Mill
until next Monday.
What instead I'm going to do
today is explain how the
transition for classical to
neoclassical utilitarianism
really went on in all fields of
thinking about the human
sciences at more or less the
same time.
There were developments in
political theory that we're
going to talk about at
considerable length,
but there were also,
under-girthing that,
developments in economics and
in philosophy that are going to
be my principle focus in today's
lecture.
What you're also going to get
as a by-product of today's
lecture is everything you ever
needed to know about
neoclassical economics in 45
minutes.
That is to say neoclassical
economics is a brilliant
intellectual creation,
to a large extent the creation
of Vilfredo Pareto,
an Italian economist that I'm
going to talk about today,
but with important
contributions from other figures
in the modern history of
economics such as Marshall,
and I'm going to mention in
some detail an economist called
Edgeworth.
And they developed a system of
thinking about economics and the
theory of value that was going
to be tremendously influential
and important not only in the
way utilitarianism evolved,
but in the way of our thinking
about markets,
legitimacy, and distributive
justice would evolve.
At the same time,
more or less,
there were very important
developments in moral philosophy
that I just want to alert you
to,
that we're going to return to
later when we come to consider
Alasdair MacIntyre's book,
After Virtue.
And this movement in philosophy
that I'm mentioning here is the
doctrine that would come to be
called emotivism.
It was associated with a man by
the name of Stevenson who wrote
several books advocating the
emotivist doctrine when he was
an untenured professor in the
Yale Philosophy Department,
and as a by-product of which,
he never became a tenured in
the Yale Philosophy Department
because his doctrine was thought
to be so repugnant.
His doctrine was that when we
make claims like murder is
wrong,
we're making claims that
express our emotions,
our emotive reactions to
propositions just as when we
say,
"I like ice cream,"
or "I prefer chocolate ice
cream to strawberry ice
cream."
All we're doing is expressing
our tastes, our emotional
reactions and that there is
nothing more to say about ethics
than that.
Now, you could say this
emotivist doctrine is an
endpoint in a philosophical
evolution that really begins in
the seventeenth century.
Hobbes, who I mentioned to you
in our very first lecture,
criticized Aristotle for not
seeing,
as Hobbes thought,
that what is desirable for some
people is not desirable for
others.
But Hobbes didn't,
truth be told,
take that view that seriously,
because he thought for the most
part we're all pretty much the
same.
And if you look at the other
classical utilitarians like
David Hume,
who we're not reading in this
course but we could read in this
course,
or Sedgwick who we're not
reading in this course but we
would have read in this course,
they also basically thought
human beings were more or less
all alike in their psychological
structure in their basic human
needs.
Hume has a famous line
somewhere to the effect that,
"If all factual questions
were resolved no moral questions
would remain."
"If all factual questions
were resolved no moral questions
would remain."
And it's not that Hume thought
we could derive an ought
statement from an is.
Hume's famous for the idea that
an ought cannot be
derived from an is;
that there's a fact-value
problem.
But he thought,
nonetheless,
people are pretty much the
same,
and so if you can figure out
what makes one of them tick you
can figure out what makes all of
them tick.
And that was most emphatically
Jeremy Bentham's view.
It's presupposed in everything
we discussed last time.
If you think about the idea of
doing interpersonal comparisons
of utility,
and making the judgment that
taking that dollar from Donald
Trump and giving it to the bag
lady increases her utility more
than it decrease his,
you're assuming that they
basically all have the same
kinds of utility functions.
Stevenson questioned that idea
radically.
He said, "We don't
actually know.
We should take Hobbes much more
seriously in his critique of
Aristotle than he was willing to
take himself.
We don't actually know if
people have the same kinds of
utility functions.
We don't know whether or not
what makes some people happy
will make others happy as
well."
And so Stevenson was thought to
be a proponent of a kind of
moral relativism because he
linked ethics to our desires,
and preferences,
and emotions,
and nothing else.
And then he said,
"It's actually an open
question."
Stevenson was criticizing Hume
on this point,
but he might as well have been
criticizing Hobbes or Bentham.
Stevenson said,
"It's an open question
whether people are alike in
their basic psychological
structures in the physiology of
their human needs."
And so that was thought to be a
radically relativist doctrine
because it seemed to undermine
the possibility of making
ethical judgments of any sort
across people.
That is a doctrine to which we
will return,
as I said, when we get to the
anti-Enlightenment and,
in particular,
Alasdair MacIntyre's book,
After Virtue.
But today we're going to focus
for the rest of our time on the
economics of the transition from
classical to neoclassical
utilitarianism.
And I'm going to ask you to
suspend disbelief for the rest
of today's lecture and just
trust me,
because what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go into this
backwards.
I'm going to come into the
transition from classical to
neoclassical economics by
looking at a very different
problem that the neoclassical
economists were concerned with
that had nothing to do with
utilitarianism,
or rights, or anything that
we've been talking about in this
lecture.
And it's not until you get to
the end of this narrative that
you'll start to see why the
transition from classical to
neoclassical utilitarianism in
economics was essential for the
transition in political theory,
and indeed for the transition
in moral philosophy.
So, as I said,
you're going to have to suspend
your disbelief and just follow
me through the ABC's of
neoclassical price theory,
which is what we're going to do
now.
And as I said,
the bonus here,
the by-product is,
you're going to get the whole
of ECON 101 reduced to a single
lecture.
Because indeed it is true that
enormously complex and subtle,
and as sophisticated as the
neoclassical theory of
microeconomics is,
it's all built out of three
ideas.
It's all built out of the three
ideas that I'm going to spell
out for you in what some of you
might initially regard as
laborious detail,
but I'm going to do it anyway,
and I think you'll see what I'm
getting at once we get towards
the end of today's discussion.
So imagine a single person.
We're going to call them A as
testimony to my lack of
imaginativeness,
but you could call them
anything you like.
And let's imagine a world in
which there are just two
commodities;
in this case wine and bread.
The system of neoclassical
utilitarianism invented by
Pareto says that,
other things being equal,
you want more rather than less
of any source of utility,
right?
We know that from classical
utilitarianism.
But if you have six bottles of
wine and only one loaf of bread,
bread is comparatively more
valuable to you than wine,
so that you would exchange a
lot of wine to get a second loaf
of bread.
If, on the other hand,
you were choking on your six
loaves of bread and dying of
thirst the reverse would be
true.
You would give up a lot of
bread in order to get a small
amount of wine.
And these are what are called
indifference curves in
neoclassical economics.
And indifference curves
basically imply exactly as the
name suggests that you would be
indifferent among the mixes of
bread and wine anywhere on this
curve.
And this curve is always shaped
that way, concave toward the
origin.
Anybody want to tell us why?
What is it reflecting?
Why is it that shape?
Someone who's done an econ
class, or somebody who remembers
Monday's lecture,
yeah?
Student:  Because of
diminishing marginal utility.
Prof: Yes, okay.
It reflects the idea of
diminishing marginal utility.
diminishing marginal utility in
exactly the sense that I just
said: that if you have a huge
amount of bread the next loaf of
bread is less valuable to you at
the margin than the previous
loaf of bread was.
So if you've got a lot of bread
you'll give up a lot of bread in
order to get a small amount of
wine, okay?
So that is the idea of
diminishing marginal utility.
And when we call this,
what I've labeled here I-1,
an indifference curve,
we're saying literally you
would get the same amount of
utility no matter where you were
on that curve.
So if you have whatever we have
here.
This isn't very well-drawn but,
say,
four bottles of wine and two
loaves of bread you would be
equally happy as if you had,
what does it look like here,
four loaves of bread and one
and a quarter bottle of wine.
You would be equally happy
between those two distributions,
okay?
What would increase your
happiness?
happiness would be get onto a
higher indifference curve.
If you could have more bread
and more wine of course you'd be
happier, right?
And so the idea of indifference
curves is that you want to go
this way.
You want to go from P toward Q.
You want to get onto,
as they put in the jargon of
neoclassical theory,
you want to get onto as high an
indifference curve as you can
possibly get.
For those of you who like the
jargon, this would be a utility
function.
You want to go up your utility
function, all the way to Q if
you could.
We don't know where Q is.
It's out in the stratosphere.
But wherever you were on your
utility function you could draw
one of these curves through it
in principle,
so if you were here,
you could find the mix of bread
and wine in each instance among
which you're going to be
indifferent.
So that is the notion of an
indifference curve.
Now, an important consideration
in the theory of indifference
curves was to say that we don't
know--
I've put these equally apart,
but, in a way,
I shouldn't have because it's
misleading.
If you get from one to two and
then you get from two to three
you haven't increased your
utility necessarily by the same
amount.
These distances don't mean
anything, okay?
I could have put three right
here because the system of
neoclassical utilitarianism,
unlike the system of classical
utilitarianism,
works with ordinal scales,
ordinal mathematical scales,
and as the word implies it
means all we do is rank order.
We rank-order our preferences,
but we don't say anything more.
So this individual A prefers
four to three,
three to two,
and two to one,
but we can't say that he
prefers or she prefers four to
three more than she prefers
three to two.
We don't know that.
We don't have a cardinal scale.
Remember that in Bentham's
system we had cardinal scales.
We were thinking of sort of
lumps of utility that could be
picked up and moved around and
redistributed to people,
right?
The neoclassical economists
didn't want to do that,
and they didn't want to do that
for a different reason than
anything I've talked about in
these lectures.
They didn't want to do that
because they were actually
concerned with quite another
problem.
The problem they wanted to
solve was to understand the
behavior of markets.
They wanted to be able to more
precisely to predict what prices
were going to be in markets,
and they wanted to do that for
reasons I'm going to elaborate
to you much later on when we
come and talk about Marx,
and the labor theory of value
and its limitations,
but that's for a future lecture.
For today's lecture all you
need to concern yourself with is
the fact that they wanted to be
able to understand the nature of
markets of how market prices
move,
but they wanted to be able to
do this with as little
information as possible.
They realized that for
Bentham's system to work,
for example,
the government would have to
have a kind of utilitometer and
run around sticking it under
people's tongues to measure
their utility,
right?
Very intrusive.
You need a lot of information
to do Bentham's system.
They wanted to say,
"How can we develop a well
articulated theory of market
prices based on as little
information about people and
their preferences as
possible?"
And Pareto, and Marshall,
and Edgeworth,
and others who were in their
circle, thought you could do
this just with ordinal utility.
So moving from cardinal to
ordinal utility is going to turn
out to have huge ideological
consequences,
which I'm going to unpack for
you towards the end of today's
lecture.
But as an analytic matter,
looking at this from the
inside,
it had the great virtue of
providing the building blocks
for a theory of price behavior
in market systems that required
almost no information about
people.
All we would know about this
person A,
as I said, is that they prefer
four to three,
three to two,
two to one, one to zero,
but we can't say anything about
how much they prefer those
things because these distances
don't actually mean anything.
All we get is an ordered
ranking.
Now, there is one other thing
we can say.
One other thing we can say is,
that this is a no-no.
These indifference curves
cannot cross.
Can anybody tell us why?
Why can't they cross?
Wait for the mic.
Student:  Because at the
intersection they should have
the same utility even though
they're different indifference
curves.
Prof: You're on the
right track, but what's the
problem with their crossing?
Student:  Because you
say I-2 has utility of two,
I-2.5 has utility of
two-point-five,
but at that point where they
intersect they both have to have
the same utility.
Prof: So you've got a
kind of contradiction on your
hands, is that right?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Okay,
and just to spell out the
contradiction more
emphatically--I think you
basically made the point.
If we're saying that we're
indifferent among all the things
on this curve and we're
on this curve we can't have it
cross because then we're saying
here,
right, two-point-five is
preferred to two,
but here we're saying the
opposite.
We're saying two is preferred
to two-point-five,
okay?
The jargon, anybody happen to
know?
Yell it out.
We don't need the mic.
Does anybody know the jargon
for this?
Student:  Transitivity.
Prof: Transitivity.
The preferences are assumed to
be transitive.
So if you prefer A to B and B
to C, you must prefer A to C.
That's all that transitive
means, okay?
If you prefer A to B and B to
C, it must be the case that you
also prefer A to C,
otherwise you're contradicting
the principle of transitivity,
okay?
So we cannot have these
indifference curves crossing one
another.
Now, what we're going to do
here, instead of one person and
two commodities,
we're going to think about two
people, okay?
We're creating a diagram with
two people on it.
As I promised you earlier in
the semester,
anything I do with a diagram I
will also do verbally,
so if you find this in any way
confusing just listen to the
narrative and then we'll see
whether you get it that way.
But so now we have a diagram
with two people on it,
okay?
So this is person A,
and this is person B.
And these axes,
the X-axis, here,
is A's utility function.
Remember A in the previous
slide was trying to get from P
towards Q, right?
A was trying to go up here.
So this, on this slide,
is the same thing as this,
on this slide.
So A is trying to go this way
and B is trying to go this way,
okay?
And what we imagine is some
distribution of utility between
them.
So A has this much utility--if
this is the status quo X,
okay?
A has this much utility and B
has this much utility.
A's happier than B, right?
Wrong, A's not.
We don't know that A's happier
than B from what I just said,
right?
These distances don't mean
anything, right?
So it looks like A's happier
than B, but that's misleading.
If the different distances are
taken to imply in your mind that
A's happier than B disabuse
yourself of that thought right
away, okay?
So we have a distribution here,
okay?
Now what Pareto said,
he said, "Let's draw a
line north-south through the
status quo,
and let's draw a line east-west
though the status quo,"
okay?
And we'll imagine that there's
a finite source of utility.
It gets called in the econ
textbooks the Pareto possibility
frontier, so there's not an
infinite source of utility.
Now, Pareto said,
"Well, if we draw the
north-south and the east-west we
get four quadrants.
We get this one.
We get this one,
and we get this one,"
right?
And what Pareto said is,
"Well, that's interesting
because we can say different
things about them."
One thing we can say is if you
can anywhere into the northeast
quadrant both of them are better
off, right?
So if we go from X to Y we know
A's utility has gone up,
and we know B's utility has
gone up, right?
We don't know by how much,
but we know it's gone up so
they're both better off.
On the other hand,
if we went anywhere in here,
this quadrant,
southwest as it were,
obviously they're both worse
off, okay?
Because if I put a point here,
Q, we'll let's not use Q--J,
let's not use,
yeah, let's use J.
If I put a point here,
J, we would say that A's gone
down and B's gone down.
Now, to make this a bit more
real imagine in here this is the
sphere of market transactions.
This is where A and B will go
voluntarily, right?
So A will say to B, "Well,
I have all this wine,
and you have all that bread,
how about I swap you a bottle
of wine for a loaf of
bread?"
And you say, "Okay."
You give it to them,
both people are better off,
okay?
And we know they're both better
off because they did it
voluntarily,
and we know they're both trying
to get onto as high an
indifference curve as possible,
right?
So they swap their wine,
they swap their bread,
and both of them are happier.
A little more tipsy,
but also a little better fed,
okay?
A move into here would be as if
the government taxes them both
and uses the money to spend on
foreign aid to a country they
both despise,
let's say.
So they both paid a tax and the
money has gone to something they
don't support.
We can say that's Pareto
inferior.
Pareto superior,
Pareto inferior,
right?
It's Pareto inferior because
they both don't want it,
and both of them would resist
it if the government tried to do
it.
Obviously they wouldn't go
there through a market
transaction because it puts both
of them on a lower indifference
curve, okay?
So that's all well and good.
Well, that leaves these two
other quadrants.
And about those two quadrants
Pareto says we can say nothing
at all.
We can say nothing at all,
at least nothing scientific.
And then he says in his famous
700-page book called The
Manual of Political Economy,
he says, "People are going
to misinterpret me.
People are going to interpret
me as saying we should never
move into either of these
quadrants.
I'm not saying that.
All I'm saying is we will never
have a scientific reason for
moving into either of these
quadrants.
Because if we were to move from
X to G,
so that we tax A by that amount
and we give it to B,
we cannot say that B's gain is
greater than A's loss because
these distances don't mean
anything despite where I put the
G.
We just have no way of knowing
because we don't allow
interpersonal comparisons of
utility.
And that's the link to
Stevenson in philosophy that I
was talking to you about
earlier.
There's no way of knowing
whether B's loss is as big as
A's gain or the reverse,
because we can't make
comparisons across individuals.
There's no scientific way to do
it.
We can't assume with Bentham,
and with Hume,
and with Sedgwick,
we can't assume that
everybody's basically the same.
Perhaps they are,
perhaps they aren't,
but we just don't know,
okay?
So that is the Pareto principle.
The Pareto principle out of
which the whole of neoclassical
economic theory was constructed
depends on this idea of
indifference curves.
A is trying to get up on those
B is trying to get along on
these indifference curves.
And we have Pareto superior,
Pareto inferior,
and then these two which he
called Pareto-undecidable
because you can't decide,
not because you're a ditherer,
but because there's no
scientific way to tell whether,
in this case,
B's loss exceeds A's gain,
and if we went up here it would
be an analogous problem.
Now, let's just suppose we go
back that A proposes to B
swapping a loaf of bread for a
bottle of wine and B agrees.
They go to Y,
and then A says,
"Well, I'll give you
another loaf of bread for
another bottle of wine."
And B says, "Forget
it."
He says, "Well,
come on, how about a half a
bottle of wine?"
He says, "Okay,"
and then they go to Z,
okay?
And if they then get to a point
at which no matter what swap A
is willing to propose,
B says no, and no matter what
swap B is willing to propose A
says no,
then you know they've hit that
frontier,
what's called the Pareto
possibility frontier.
Because now there's no way to
make B better off without making
A worse off, okay?
They will--"What about a
half a bottle?
What about a quarter of a
bottle?
Well, then I want two-thirds of
a loaf.
No, that's too much,"
blah, blah, blah,
back and forth,
"Forget it,
I'm off,"
okay?
When no transaction occurs,
you know they've hit that
frontier.
So, the Pareto principle says
that in a market system they'll
move toward the frontier and
when they get there,
they'll stop.
Now, of course,
they may have gotten there some
way else.
They might have gone from X to
G over here, and then they would
have done a new one,
and then they might have gone
to here, and so on.
And that would just reflect
shrewdness in bargaining,
or how much people cared lower
down their indifference curves,
or other idiosyncrasies.
But once they wind up anywhere
on this indifference curve
they're not going to move off of
it because now there is no way
of improving one person's
utility without diminishing the
next person's utility,
and that is what is called
Pareto optimal,
okay?
So Y is Pareto superior to X,
and Z is Pareto optimal,
can't be improved upon.
It's an optimum in that sense.
That's it.
That is neoclassical economic
theory in a nutshell.
Now, I'm going to show you one
more diagram that will possibly
look intimidating when I first
put it up,
but all it does is put the
preceding diagrams that we've
just looked at together.
And this is what in the econ
literature--it was invented by
an economist called Edgeworth,
and it's called an Edgeworth
box diagram.
And let me explain for you
diagrammatically,
and then if anybody doesn't get
it we'll wait up and I'll go
through it more slowly.
But think about the diagram we
just did, okay?
Think about A is here in the
corner, okay?
But basically now we're putting
the two previous diagrams
together.
Maybe I'll just go back so
everybody's clear what we're
doing.
We're putting this diagram,
where we have two commodities
and one person,
and this diagram where we have
two people and just utility
we're putting it all together,
okay, into one big picture.
And so you'll see why this is
helpful once we get to the end
of it.
So A is here,
and A has indifference curves.
This is our first picture,
right?
So A is tying to go northeast.
We have A.
We have wine.
We have bread.
A's indifference curves are the
dotted lines,
okay?
A is trying to get that way,
that way, that way,
and to keep going all that way,
right?
And what Edgeworth did--it
wasn't that it was a late night
or anything that I put this
writing upside down--
he said, "Just imagine a
mirror going down here."
B is coming at A from the other
corner, okay?
So B is looking at bottles of
wine, loaves of bread,
and B has now got the solid
indifference curves,
and B is trying to go this way,
right?
B is trying to go this way.
So A would improve if he went
this way, and B would improve if
she went this way,
okay?
So this is an indifference
curve for B.
Now, it's going southwest
instead of northeast just
because it's looking in the
mirror.
B is A looking in the mirror,
get it, okay?
So B wants to go this way,
as I said, southwest;
A wants to go northeast.
So if you imagine that this
were the status quo from right
where A has almost all of the
bread,
right, and B has almost all of
the wine,
then this shaded area here,
this big football,
is the Pareto superior set on
the previous diagram.
Because if you think about it,
it's the set that if you move
anywhere in the biggest football
I've shaded here--
let's say we started here at X
where A had almost all the wine
and B had almost all of the
bread.
If they went from X to Y,
A would be on a higher
indifference curve because A
would have gone from here to
here,
and B coming the other way
would also be on a higher
indifference curve,
and you could draw a new
football, right?
It would be a smaller football
within the bigger football.
And then they haggle again.
And A says, "Well,
what about half a bottle?"
B says, "Well,
then I want three-quarters of a
loaf," blah,
blah, back and forth,
and they wind up at Z.
And you know Z is on the Pareto
possibility frontier because
every proposal that one makes,
the other rejects,
right?
And so you capture it in an
Edgeworth box by having their
indifference curves be points of
tangency.
So at Z, A wants to go this
way, but the only way that A can
go this way would move B off his
or her indifference curve,
which is this one coming this
way, okay?
So the Edgeworth box diagram
just puts all of the pictures
together.
There's nothing conceptually
new in it at all,
and it only becomes relevant to
our purposes because it will
enable us to start thinking
about distributive questions,
which I will get to in a minute.
Okay, let me pause because I
want to be sure--have I gone
through his too quickly?
Would anyone like me to walk
through it again?
If you think you would want me
to walk through it again
probably half the people in the
room do, so don't feel awkward.
It's actually a lot simpler
than it looks,
right?
I mean, all you have to do is
take the previous,
the Pareto principle diagram
and imagine it with a mirror and
think of B as upside down coming
toward A,
and then it just all fits
together.
Very clever.
Okay and the one thing I would
say, this line here is what on
the previous diagram was the
Pareto possibility frontier,
right?
This line is all the points of
tangency between--like there is
one, there is one,
there is one.
So you join up all the points
at which the indifference curves
are at tangents to one another.
That is the line where if they
get onto this line they won't
move off of it voluntarily,
right?
By definition.
So they went from X,
to Y, to Z, but perhaps if A
had driven a harder bargain
early on,
they might have gone by a
different path and would have
wound up at a different point.
This is the Pareto possibility
frontier which Edgeworth called
the contract curve.
It's the same thing.
It's where they will make a
contract to get to.
They will agree to transactions
that get them onto that curve,
but once they're on it they
stay there, okay?
That's the basic intuition.
So market transactions into the
Pareto superior zone,
and eventually they stop when
things are Pareto optimal.
Now, let's think about
comparing classical and
neoclassical utilitarianism.
If you think back to Monday's
lecture we said with Bentham's
utility anything--this isn't a
very good forty-five degrees is
it?
I guess it is.
It just depends where you stand.
With Bentham's utility we said
that anything in this whole
area,
the first shaded area,
maximizes the greatest
happiness of the greatest
number, right?
That was his imperative.
The Pareto principle,
we now know,
singles out this Pareto
superior area as unambiguously
better because people will go
there voluntarily.
So everything that is Pareto
superior is Bentham superior,
right?
Everything that's Pareto
inferior is Bentham inferior,
right?
This is uninteresting.
It's unambiguously worse
whether you're a classical or a
neoclassical utilitarian,
right?
So everything that's Pareto
superior is Bentham superior.
Everything that's Pareto
inferior is Bentham inferior.
But now the interesting stuff,
which is where all of
redistributive politics goes on,
and all the battles in politics
go on,
are in the two Pareto
undecidable quadrants,
right?
This one and this one,
about which Pareto says,
as a matter of science,
we can say nothing,
and Bentham disagrees,
right?
Bentham's principle bisects
these Pareto undecidable
quadrants because Bentham makes
his interpersonal judgments of
utility.
And so Bentham says,
if you go into this area,
it's a Bentham improvement,
though it's Pareto undecidable,
whereas if you go into this
area, it's not a Bentham
improvement even though it's
Pareto undecidable.
So Bentham and Sedgwick,
and Hume,
and the classical utilitarians
think we can make interpersonal
judgments which allow us to say
when it will make sense for the
government to tax A,
and benefit B,
whereas Pareto says there's no
way to tell.
Again, he says,
"People are going to
interpret me as saying the
government should never
redistribute.
I'm not saying that,
and it's a misuse of my
doctrine to say that.
All I'm saying is if the
government chooses to
redistribute,
there's not going to be a
scientific principle to tell
them how."
So just to make the point
dramatic let's suppose--we're
going back to the Edgeworth
diagram.
Let's suppose this is the
status quo.
That is, let's suppose B has
everything and A has nothing.
B has all the wine and all the
bread.
We know they're on the contract
curve because B has nothing that
A wants, right?
So if you think,
again, of Trump and the bag
lady, she has nothing that he
wants, so the Pareto efficient
outcome is for the bag lady to
starve.
It might not be morally
defensible, but it's the Pareto
efficient outcome.
They're on the contract curve.
There is nothing you can do to
improve the bag lady's utility
that will not diminish Trump's
utility, right?
Now you could say,
"But of course,
she's on the verge of
starvation.
How can that possibly be the
case," but notice we've
ruled out interpersonal
comparisons of utility now.
And so proponents of
neoclassical utilitarianism have
no way to make interpersonal
judgments of utility.
So the Pareto efficient
transaction is no transaction,
and the bag lady starves to
death.
You'll see when we come to read
John Rawls later in the semester
he says the trouble with
utilitarianism is that it
doesn't take seriously the
differences among persons.
The trouble with
utilitarianism,
says John Rawls in His
Theory of Justice,
is that is doesn't take
seriously the differences among
persons.
You now know enough to see that
actually Rawls' argument is
half-right, because the truth is
that's the problem with
classical utilitarianism.
Classical utilitarianism says,
"Well,
if taking all of your utility
and giving it to me increases
overall net utility then we
should do that,
because you improve the
greatest happiness of the
greatest number."
We don't care who has the
utility, right?
So classical utilitarianism is
indeed vulnerable to Rawls'
critique, it doesn't take
seriously the differences
between persons,
right?
And we saw that when you allow
interpersonal judgments of
utility and interpersonal
comparisons you get the
radically redistributive
doctrine that Bentham then tries
to fend off with his distinction
between absolute and practical
equality that we talked about
last time.
But Rawls' point doesn't
actually apply.
The problem with neoclassical
utilitarianism is that it takes
the differences between
individuals hyper-seriously,
so seriously that you would say
the bag lady should starve in
this example rather than have
something redistributed to her
by the state,
forcibly taken from Trump.
So classical utilitarianism
ignores the differences among
individuals;
neoclassical utilitarianism
fetishizes the differences among
people to an incredible extreme
so that proponents of
neoclassical utilitarianism,
like Richard Posner in his book
The Economics of Justice,
concedes that it's a problem
with your neoclassical
utilitarianism that if you have
a disabled person who's not
capable of working for anybody
else there's no reason,
or as he puts it,
"contributing to anybody
else's utility function,"
there's no reason that that
person shouldn't be allowed to
die.
And Posner says,
"Well, that's a problem
with utilitarianism."
And he throws ups his hands and
says, "I don't really know
what to do about it,"
and he moves one.
It's a deep problem with
neoclassical utilitarianism.
But notice from the point of
view of the history of
ideologies what has happened in
this transition from classical
to neoclassical utilitarianism.
We've gone from a world in
which the doctrine of classical
utilitarianism was a very
radical idea that would
legitimate huge redistribution
by the state,
into a world in which the
radical fangs of classical
utilitarianism have been ripped
out and it is now a doctrine
that is very friendly to
whatever status quo happens to
be generated in a market system.
So it ceases to be this
radically redistributive
doctrine,
and in the process imports into
utilitarianism a very robust,
some would say,
hyper-robust doctrine of
individual rights,
and we'll see how that played
out in political theory when we
come to look at John Stuart
Mills' harm principle next
Monday.